has anyone ever told you that you have
your father's eyes and your mother's
nose
well you inherit these traits from your
parents through chromosomes human cells
are diploid that is they have two copies
of each chromosome one from each parent
now let's imagine two people who both
have chin dimples person a is a
homozygote which means that they have
two chromosomes both containing the same
version of the gene in this case both
chromosomes carry the chin dimple gene
person B is a heterozygote which means
that each chromosome carries a different
version of the gene here one chromosome
carries a chin dimple gene and one
carries a smooth chin gene each of these
people's gametes either sperm or eggs
will be produced by a process of
division this division is called meiosis
watch how these cells each divide to
create four cells each containing only
one chromosome of each pair six of the
gametes contain the chin dimple gene
while to contain the smooth chin gene
personai only has chin dimple gene
gametes so they have a 100% chance of
passing on the chin dimple gene to their
offspring person B however has a 50%
chance of passing on a smooth chin gene
at 50% chance of passing on a chin
dimple gene what if we wanted to ensure
that person be passed on the smooth chin
gene we would need to ensure that the
only made gametes containing smooth chin
genes this is where a gene drive system
would come in handy gene drives which
occur in various forms our mechanism
cells can use to promote one variant of
a gene over another in other words they
can help change a heterozygous
population into a homozygous one they
can occur in nature but with the advent
of a new and powerful gene editing
technology called CRISPR casts nine
scientists are learning how to
manipulate gene drives to create desired
outcomes let's take a closer look at how
it works let's return to our person a
with homozygous chin dimple genes and
our person be with heterozygous dimple
and smooth chin genes if a scientist
attached a gene drive to the smooth chin
gene in purse
and be the gene drive would convert the
chin dimple gene on their other
chromosome into a smooth chin gene now
person B has a 100% chance of passing
down a smooth chin gene but there's more
remember that the scientists inserted
the CRISPR machinery along with the gene
that means that the CRISPR mechanism is
also copied into the second edited
chromosome along with the gene this
means that the second chromosome now has
the mechanism to carry out the gene
drive itself in other words gene drive
with CRISPR is self-replicating once an
individual's chromosome has been edited
all the offspring of that individual
will also have the edit after having
used gene drive person a and person B
have a 100% chance of creating a
heterozygous offspring with one smooth
chin and one chin dimple gene but
because the smooth chin gene carries the
CRISPR machinery it will convert the
chin dimple gene from person a into a
smooth chin gene with gene drive now the
offspring of person a and person B is
homozygous for the smooth chin gene and
any of their offspring will also be
homozygous while it is unlikely that
gene drive would ever actually be used
on humans for ethical reasons there have
been proposals to use it on mosquitoes
to eliminate the many diseases they
carry including malaria yellow fever and
Zika
there were several environmental
concerns that need to be addressed
because if released into the wild gene
drives could alter entire species within
a few generations
additionally there are ethical concerns
should humans be altering genomes in
such a dramatic and impactful way what
should the legal barriers surrounding
gene drives be and how the countries
come to agreements on regulations these
are the questions that the public
scientists and lawmakers will need to
begin addressing in the near future